Congratulations youtubers! you survived
Comic Con this is going to be my
breakdown of the guardians of the galaxy
to trailer they aired so probably the
most comic book thing in a weekend full
of comic book stuff so all the movies
that Marvel brought to comic-con
they're still working on Doctor Strange
is the only one that's pretty much done
like they're probably finishing some
special effects for that but of all the
movies that are still in production
guardians of the galaxy 2 is the
furthest along so naturally they had the
most footage for that there were really
like two different parts of footage that
he showed off so it wasn't like two
trailers but there was a highlight reel
then there was a more traditional type
of trailer just as a way to show you
where all the characters are and how how
much crazier things have gotten it's
really turned into like a $200,000,000
Rick and Morty episode it's so amazing
you have absolutely no idea like think
about the Captain America movies that
Captain America Civil War had a lot of
comic book things in it had Spider Man
holding Captain America's shield talking
about Empire Strikes Back that was like
the peak comic book moment this year for
me next year guardians of the galaxy 2
is going to blow that away so here just
to break down exactly what the footage
was we pick up with the Ravagers that's
the group that yondu controlled in the
last film
they have since revolted so like there
are a bunch of Ravagers that they
brought to Comic Con so like they revolt
against yondu you see baby Groot and
they have to organize a prison break and
it's all about baby Groot getting yondu
his fin back so for those of you that
said that yondu in the first movie
wasn't comic-book yondu enough they are
going full comic book in this movie like
Michael Rooker came to comic-con in full
makeup with the fin on so this is kind
of what it looks like it's kind of
plasticky looking it glows and it allows
him to control his arrow select in the
last film he was whistling to control
the arrow the fin itself just does that
in a much more visual way so there was
this scene where baby Groot gets his fin
bit like steals it back from the
Ravagers yon who uses it to take them
all down the Ravagers make jokes about
baby Groot they put him in this tiny
like little adorable Ravagers uniform so
you have like dancing baby Groot wearing
a tiny uniform he's super pissed about
it but then his yondu starts killing all
these people baby Groot actually selects
one ravager uses his plant powers to
like reach out and throw him off a
balcony so one of the funniest parts of
the footage was watching baby Groot
brutally murder a Ravager so why is he
still a baby you ask well you know I'm
sure there's a lot of merchandising
reasons
but they use it to their advantage like
as part of this Prison Break he can get
in and out of really tiny spaces so this
is funny montage of him bringing back
all these wrong items when he's looking
for yondu's Finn he comes back with a
prosthetic eye in Rocket Raccoon is like
even though it's the wrong item it's not
the Finn he grabs it and is like this is
going to be so funny he's going to wake up and not know what the hell happened so if
you wonder why yondu is part of the
Guardians he's not part of the Ravagers
in the second film you can see how
they've revolted and that drives him to
the Guardians so like you know here's
this connection with Peter he's kind of
like Peter Quill's adopted father
so yondu will just be traveling with the
Guardians for most of the film the
Ravagers themselves are kind of an
antagonist and that theme continues so
they revealed Elizabeth to Vicky's
character she's playing the kismet
character she's like the leader of this
genetically perfect race so she hires
the Guardians to save them from this
interdimensional beast but things go
completely off the rails
so she winds up being something of an
antagonist too we see Sylvester
Stallone's character that's right
Sylvester Stallone is in the movie he's
one of the rat like he's wearing a
Ravagers uniform but they didn't reveal
who he is so what I think is going to
happen is is he'll be like a super deep
cut from the comics that'll make you
scream in the movie theater without
necessarily tying him to future films
like he's not going to be Adam warlock
or something like that it'll be like a
Howard the Duck type Easter egg like oh
my god that's a huge character but like
Howard the Duck wasn't super critical to
the plot of the movie he was just a
really cool easter egg speaking of which
Adam warlock his cocoon was a big easter
egg for the movie I'm going to talk about
Adam warlock and how he's kind of in the
movie without actually physically being
in the movie we see the Guardians having
a really funny argument about fighting
this interdimensional creature
Peter quit like a big portal opens up in
the distance and Peter Quill's like
Showtime assholes Peter and rocket are
yelling at each other and Peter calls
him a stupid raccoon he gets really
offended in Peter's like sorry I meant
trash Panda fingers crossed that they
released some merchandise with rocket
racoon that's just labeled as trash
Panda but then then we get the big
reveal of star wars father so just
careful for spoilers if you don't want
to know about star Lords father because
it is a super deep cut from the comics
so they're walking through a forest and
then this very Adam warlock II cocoon
descends it looks like an egg in out
steps mantis and Kurt Russell wearing
you know this you
form Peter Quill's like who the hell are
you supposed to be and then Kurt
Russell's characters like I figured my
rugged good looks we've made that
obvious my name is ego and I'm your dad Peter
all the Guardians crap their pants it
gets really awkward but then they take
it right back by doing the math about
how he could possibly be a living planet
and be Peters father he explains that
he's a living planet but he made himself
a human body and then probably the
funniest moment of the trailer Drax is
like wait you made yourself a human body
did you make yourself and then
you know everybody starts throwing up in
their mouths and then completely
unphased egos like yes tracks I've got a
and Drax is like thank you so if
in 2016 peak comic book is spider-man in
a Marvel movie holding Captain America
shield talking about Empire Strikes Back
then next year the guardians talking
about the of a living planet will
be peak comic book so just to tie it
back to Adam warlock so like a lot of
people were like maybe Peter Quill's
fathers Adam warlock because he has the
soul gem in the comics and Peter quill
would have to be part engine tin order
to be able to hold an infinity gem so a
lot of people were like okay well
they're just like a few people that that
could be so Adam warlock was just the
biggest candidate so while it turns out
that ego is his father which is way
better in my book it's a way deeper cut
from the comics I think visually you
will see a lot of Adam warlock Easter
eggs in Kurt Russell's character so even
though James Gunn changed a bunch of
stuff from the comics he found a really
funny way to keep all that stuff in the
movie so they don't really explain the
mechanics of how star Lord's father made
himself a human body how his powers work so I think that's going to tie into the
soul gem I just feel like it's so weird
and there's so many big crazy thing like
interdimensional beasts that they have
to stop in this movie that it demands
the presence of a soul gem which is why
I think the time gem is what's going to
be showing up during Doctor Strange
because even in the Doctor Strange
trailer the ancient one is like I have
been searching all of time for so long
looking for you so the concept of time
is very important to the Doctor Strange
movie but the Guardians movie is mostly
about family relationships now yes on a
really simple level James Gunn said it's
all about baby Groot and star-lords
father but really it's about family
relationships so there's going to be a
lot of awkward family comedy like
yondu's former family the Ravagers turn
on him so he seeks a new family
in the Guardians Peter quill finds his
father you also meet this race of
genetically perfect people that are a
bunch of assholes so thematically the movie is telling you
you know that it's all about the family
that you choose for yourself and being
perfect is not important like you don't
have to be perfect so the film will be
really easy to flexo matically it'll be
really easy to follow you could take
your grandma to it even if she does
absolutely no idea what comic books are
she would totally love it so that is
part of the magic of James Gunn I feel
like he's one of the best comic book
authors working in films today just
because he has such a deep understanding
of the comics like he is a lifelong
comic book nerd but he also has a really
strong vision and he's a writer so you
tend to find that the best comic book
movies come from directors that also
write their films that also have a
lifelong history with those characters
so James going to just one of those
directors that make such awesome movies
that I like I don't use I don't even
care what they're about like even if it
wasn't about comic books I would
automatically say shut up and take my
money like another good example is Joss
Whedon someone with a really strong
vision that writes all of his stuff and
directs it but mark my words
next summer guardians of the galaxy 2
will be peak comic book there's a whole
bunch of really awesome comic book
movies coming out next year like Wonder
Woman is going to be amazing gal gadot
is going to be fantastic but guardians
of the galaxy 2 will be the most comic
book of all comic book things next year
more fantastic than the of a
Living Planet
I want a t-shirt of ego the Living
Planet with text that reads my is
fantastic I would totally wear something
like that around in public so let me
know what do you guys think about what
you've heard about guardians of the
galaxy 2 so far like you've seen the
look of the Ravagers and even though
James Gunn has said he's not releasing
the footage you will probably see all
this stuff in November when Doctor
Strange premieres they'll probably
attach the guardians of the galaxy
trailer to that he was like yes I know
when the trailer is going to drop but I
can't say yet like they can't reveal but
they typically attach a big trailers for
future movies to other big Disney movies
so just expect to see a whole bunch of
guardians of the galaxy stuff later this
year in November but giveaway time
there's a new round of the giveaway
that's going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video there's
still a couple Marvel videos that I want
to get through but like the DC TV shows
are doing Legion of Doom next year
legends of tomorrow there's a couple
more trailers I need to get through so
I'm going to try and post all that stuff
at least by the end of Tuesday so
there's still a whole bunch of stuff
coming if there's something that I
haven't done that you guys want me to do
a video for from comic-con
just let me know in the comments it was
such an awesome marathon this weekend I
was really happy with comic-con Marvel
did an amazing panel my next video will
probably be Planet Hulk Thor Ragnarok
because they showed off Hulk's armor
during Thor Ragnarok they actually
brought it from the set of the movie so
Hulk is going to be awesome gladiator
Hulk in that movie while you guys wait
for me to post that you can click here
for my breakdown of the
Spider-Man homecoming trailer and you can click here for my breakdown of the
Game Of Thrones Season 7 teaser thank you so much for watching everybody let's high five,
I'll see you guys tonight!